Speaker 1: Let's go to David from Florida.
David from Florida. What's going on? I may
be making my triumphant return to Florida
very soon.
Speaker 2: Oh, nice. Where are you headed?
Speaker 1: Usually the Miami area.
Speaker 2: I look forward to crowded for my
face then. I just. I just had two questions
for you. One, your opinion on the fact that
it seems neither of the parties are going
to be participating in debates, at least at
least the Republican conference did say that
they would have won. It's just Trump may not
be participating, but the fact that Biden
doesn't even want to talk to Marianne or Kennedy
seems a little messed up for me.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen, I would like
to see debates on both sides. I think Trump
not showing up is pathetic. And I think that
the DNC should organize debates. But I'm also
not naive, obviously. Why? If you are if you
have an incumbent president and you have as
a priority making the incumbent president
president for four more years, why would you
take the risk? And I know people say, well,
if it were Obama, there would be less risk
because Obama is better at public speaking
them. But whatever. Why would you create a
situation with the risk that your eventual
nominee ends up hurting themselves with a
bad debate performance? It's sort of like,
obviously, I'm always for debate and more
conversation, but it's also so obvious that
it would be a completely unforced risk for
the DNC to to try to force Biden to debate.
Speaker 2: Right. And given his age and the
fact that he has seemingly more difficulty
to speak. Not that he doesn't get anything
done. He does. It's just it's a little bit
more public appearances, you know, not doing
as good as he used to.
Speaker 1: Yeah, but it's not. It's not because,
I mean, the when you have an incumbent running
for reelection.
Speaker 3: You don't do the.
Speaker 2: Big if he does go to debate and
he gets he gets, you know trials that just
makes him look even worse as the incumbent.
So people would be more likely to vote otherwise.
I completely understand what you're saying.
Yeah. All right. My second thing was about
the Florida Senate Bill 7050, where they slipped
in the fact that you can now run for other
office if you're running for the presidency.
Speaker 1: I actually did not see that. But
I know that there was a discussion of changing
that. And of course, it's specifically for
for Ron DeSantis. Yeah, I didn't I actually
didn't see that that passed.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Farron Cousins actually does
video about it. It was last Friday, I believe
that they put it through, of course, behind
closed doors, saying that if you were to run
for office in other other offices like that,
would you'd have to resign first, resign to
run. And then they put in if you're going
for the presidency now, that's totally cool.
Go for it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, I mean, listen, we
all know the whole point of that. I still
don't know 100% whether DeSantis is or isn't
going to announce. I mean, I think he probably
will, but I think it's possible he'll get
talked out of it. But it's very clear that
they're setting the stage for him to run if
he wants to.
Speaker 2: Well, if he does, it might pull
away a little bit of some Republican votes,
but we'll see what happens in 24. Thanks for
taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right, David from Florida.
There he goes. Let's go next to L.J. from
Las Vegas. L.J. from Las Vegas. Welcome to
the program. What's on your mind?
Speaker 3: Hey, David. How you been.
Speaker 1: Doing? Well.
Speaker 3: Good. And I have a kind of a rough
cut on some things. So it's not 100% thought
through. But I just kind of want to get your
thought on it, if that's cool. Sure. So I
know we always talk about like every single
year the black community being a very big
part of the Democratic Party and the like.
One of the most reliable voting blocs for,
you know, Democrats, in a sense. Yes. I kind
of wondered what some of the things that we
can do because I'm Hispanic myself. Right.
To activate more Hispanic people, more Mexicans,
more Cubans, more just the block in general,
to kind of create more, you know, discussion
around like, you know, opening the border
for people who are good. You know, And again,
this is, again, a a rough cut of our ideas.
I just kind of want to get your point of view
on that.
Speaker 1: Well, here's the thing. One of
the things that I try to resist is assuming
that in order to get a certain group involved,
you need to cater or pander with particular
issues above and beyond the general idea that
there are all sorts of different reasons why
they should be engaged with politics. Now,
obviously we can't ignore that different groups
have different priorities. So if a population
that is more likely to have family in Central
and South America is almost certainly going
to be more motivated by certain issues than
people that don't, and that might relate to
everything from so-called chain migration
to dark, permanent status, all these different
things. But one of the things I think is really
important is if we identify not necessarily
a group, but people who aren't engaging politically,
first, we should be having a general conversation
about why aren't you engaged, why aren't you
voting, whatever the case may be, before automatically
jumping to like, for example, if there were
a bunch of, say, gay men who weren't voting,
I wouldn't necessarily go straight in on LGBT
rights, for example. I would first just want
to know, why aren't you? Why aren't you engaged?
Because the reason they're not engaged may
actually not be related specifically to issues
of LGBT rights. And obviously it's important
to say, Hey, it might be of particular importance
for you to get involved, because right now
one party actually wants to strip rights specifically
from folks based on an identity that you share.
But I would start with the more general reasons
to be involved politically.
Speaker 3: Hmm. Definitely. It's just it's
interesting because as someone who grew up
here in Vegas, right in Nevada, it's 20% of
the population is Hispanic. Right. And within
Nevada State, according to the Census Bureau.
So, you know, I don't know how accurate that
is, but that's at least our numbers that I
can recall.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't have them in front
of me. I'll take your word for it.
Speaker 3: Yeah. But in that sense, right.
I do feel like there's always this assumption
that the Hispanic vote, or at least in my
personal view, that people don't think it's
as important or as valued as, let's say, the
black vote or the mothers in suburban neighborhoods.
Right. And my thought is, why couldn't there
be a discussion more to include Hispanic families?
Nevada, or at least Las Vegas, has one of
the best unions in the entire country. Right.
The Culinary Workers Union. Yes. And I feel
like as Hispanics, that's a very big thing
that we should be focusing on is increasing
the size of the union and using Nevada as
a template for why unions should work across
the country.
Speaker 1: I agree 100%. And I as you know,
I was born in Argentina, moved to the U.S.,
Hispanic, immigrant, etc.. I agree with you
100% that it is a group that I think should
be. It's not a question of targeting, but
understood more. And I completely agree with
everything you're saying.
Speaker 3: Cool. Thank you. Appreciate it.
Speaker 1: All right. LJ from Las Vegas. There
he goes. Let's go to Oh, I don't know. How
about how about Chris from Texas? Chris, what's
going on today? You hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: David? Yes? Can you hear me? Yes.
Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Okay. Okay. So I guess one thing
I was having a question about was what are
your thoughts on the Jordan Neely death?
Speaker 1: You know, I saw that. Eric Adams.
So this is the death of this was a man who
was. Correct me if I'm wrong, Chris. This
is a man who was killed on a New York City
subway, basically put in a chokehold for like
10 minutes or something like that after.
Speaker 3: 15.
Speaker 1: 15 minutes. You know, and I want
to be careful here after maybe acting sort
of aggressively, but it's like not really
totally clear. Right. I mean, I think that
this is kind of what there's debate over.
And I saw Eric Adams, the mayor of New York
City, put out a statement that was kind of
quite weird, just very generically condemning
tragedy, but talking about mental illness
and things that are not not even totally clear.
I don't I'm kind of reserving judgment because
I just want to learn more about it. I read
a couple of stories about it and I saw some
statements, but I don't want to say anything
wrong until I know more.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I guess for me, it just makes
me kind of a little worried just because I
guess for me, I'm black and autistic as well
and I feel like I a lot of the times when
it comes to mental health, our country doesn't
really do much service for people that are
in need of mental health treatment or who
have or who are in poverty as well. And I
kind of feel like some of the policies that
Eric Adams has done when it comes to like
increasing police funding while cutting like
social services, like for education and lights
and and health and and health care and housing
has kind of probably exacerbated the problem,
in my opinion.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, what I don't want
to do is to start characterizing the incident
as anything other than than what it is. It
has the potential to basically be a sort of
vigilantism that we should be extremely concerned
about it. It has the possibility of being
a mental illness story as well. I just I just
want to know more. It is a tragedy, without
a doubt. But I want to know more details before
I kind of like give what might be a more definitive
take about it. But from what I've read and
seen so far, extraordinarily concerning.
Speaker 3: Yeah, but I guess also regarding
vigilante vigilantism. How can we probably
address, like, lately, like with laws to prevent
more vigilante justice? Because I feel like
it's been getting out of hand. Like, especially
I remember there is this one kid who was shot
from a what? From a white old white guy, from
some other state as well.
Speaker 1: Yeah. The issue with vigilantism
is that it it directly relates to how self-defense
laws are written and enforced. And that can
include stand your Ground, castle doctrine,
etc.. So it really comes down to state law
on a lot of those issues. And you deal with
people. People's willingness to participate
in vigilantism is going to directly relate
to their understanding of self-defense law
in their state. And so that's the context
in which it needs to be thought through.
Speaker 3: So probably we will need to do
something more along the lines of trying to
educate people better in terms of how our
self-defense laws work and also trying to
maybe change the voting, the the laws regarding
self-defense as well.
Speaker 1: Potentially. Potentially. And it
depends on state to state. Yeah. Chris, thank
you for bringing it up. I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: All right. Thank you for the call,
David.
Speaker 1: All right. There goes Chris from
Texas. Thanks for calling in today. We're
going to take a quick break and the Thursday
show is going to continue.